childhood nostalgia is a funny thing it
can really color your perception of how
you viewed something but mixing it in
with happy memories of the good old days
so your pre-adolescent mind can trick
your future adult self into thinking
MORTAL KOMBAT the journey begins was
awesome only to watch it and go or maybe
you can go back and find something that
you hate it as a kid is pretty cool as
an adult like cussing helps maybe that I
try not to let nostalgia play a factor
in how I review things by just looking
at them how I would if I only saw them
today for the first time with new eyes
and a fresh look I want to go back to a
topic from my own childhood superhero
games based on insanely collectible toys
which is admittedly a very specific
niche considering there's like only two
of them maybe three but before we get
into the history behind these two I want
to talk about this video being made
possible by our gracious sponsors
another highly collectible and addictive
game raid Shadow Legends is a dark
fantasy epic RPG that I'm sure you've
heard of by now in fact it's so popular
it's had over 15 million downloads in
the last six months alone raid is one of
the top three ranked RPGs on the Google
Play Store and it's just been nominated
as a finalist for Google play's best of
2019 users Choice Award it's a hero
collection turn-based game with over 400
champions for you to collect and
personally customized you can play it
and assemble a team from 16 factions
discover 13 cool locations and raid with
your friends in a clan and the best part
it's totally free to play some extra
cool features in the game are 14 new
champions added every month to keep that
collection growing progression rewards
like free champions and equipment just
for learning how to play and once you
completed those missions you'll get one
of the best legendary champions in the
game the arbiter this game is growing
super fast and has even more updates
coming downline so you'll never get
bored go to the video description click
the special links and you'll get 50,000
silver and a free epic champion as part
of the new player program to start your
journey good luck and I'll see you there
all right where was I now
all right complaining about a game for
10-year olds but first context this is
Darth Vader or at least a very cutesy
and kid-friendly version of him from the
toy line called
two heroes that first started in the
mid-2000s just about every kid I knew
had at least one or two of these things
and even though I wasn't that big into
Star Wars I had I had a lot of them
they're like Funko pops except you can
actually play with them and they aren't
all the same default template doing
there were such a hit that they spawned
in a new territory by licensing other
franchises so the simple cute-looking
not very posable toys started to take on
the likeness of Indiana Jones
transformers and one day Marvel
superheroes I collected all the above
including the really rare ones that you
had to get by sending in special box
tops I was obsessed with these things as
a kid the Super Hero Squad series in
particular because I was such a huge
comic fan growing up they weren't just a
favorite for yours truly the Super Hero
Squad toys were so huge that they
spawned a cartoon and multiple video
games and I was the prime target
audience at the time given how young I
was and yet despite my love and
adoration for these things in my eternal
quest to bug my parents to hunt down
every single one that existed I didn't
like the game I especially didn't like
the show and that's a topic for another
day but I played the game once and then
traded it in shortly after a few years
later Super Hero Squad toys started
dying down and going unsold in stores
until they stopped producing them
entirely
one day I knew for sure that I had
collected my last one and I'm sure if I
ran down the checklist I'd probably
realize I have all but three or four of
them by then I was getting older and
stopped playing with toys as much I was
too busy at school starting to take
notice of girls and entering the early
stages of teenage angst then I'm pretty
sure I'm still mixed up in at twenty-one
around twenty thirteen though Lego
acquired about all the licenses for
Marvel that they could ever want and
went full force with toys and
merchandise to hype up the MCU
Renaissance after Avengers came out and
very quickly after that they put out
Lego Marvel superheroes a game I bought
on day one and played day in and day out
until I got 100% completion I've played
it several times since then and I have
so many fond memories with this game
that got me thinking
I love Super Hero Squad toys but I
didn't like the game I didn't care about
Lego Marvel toys but I adored the game
so today I want to explore and tackle
the question of why this game is such a
nostalgia trip and this one's a
forgotten memory despite being based on
brands with totally opposite effects
maybe along the way we'll learn how not
to make a superhero game for kids so
both of these games start out pretty
similarly a smiley plastic vision of the
good old Marvel Universe where a cosmic
accident gets everyone's attention by
leaving a series of super-powered
MacGuffins all over the place causing
Doctor Doom to take notice and send his
Legion of bad guys to go pick them up
well Iron Man and his crew tread play
keep-away both have linear gameplay
segments where two players explore
levels fight hordes of bad guys and
solve admittedly easy puzzles and beat
up abomination in the first level on the
surface these almost seem like the same
game but the devil is in the details and
the execution plays a big part in why
both got such a different reaction from
me let's look at Super Hero Squad first
since it came out a few years before
Lego Marvel the game's art style is
strange and a little off-putting the
characters aren't based on the cartoon
based on the toys they're just based on
the toys to the point of looking really
plastic and stiff and mimicking the
facial expressions the figures had in
these motion comic style cutscenes even
in gameplay they strike poses just like
the figures during in-game animations I
have a few theories as to why the
positive one being that maybe they just
wanted an art style where these
characters look good in 3d since the 2d
designs from the show might have looked
a little odd or the other one being that
there just wasn't a lot of communication
about the character designs from the
show during development the game only
came out over a month after the premiere
of the animated show so they were
probably rushing to get it out the door
in time this makes it feel really
strange as a tie-in because it doesn't
really feel or look much like the show
despite having their voice actors and a
bit of their character are in the menus
so it fits in this nebulous space of not
belonging anywhere it's too much like
the show to feel like a tribute to the
toys and it's not enough like the show
to feel like a good tie in for that not
only does it feel rushed and out of
place in the history
it just feels rushed and out of place in
every other way to the game itself feels
like a clunky mess that was pretty
irritating as a kid the combat is
extremely button mashing with very low
input on how much or how little damn
you're doing enemies your first instinct
is to just hit square until they fall
down but what happens if you hit
triangle nada but if you hit triangle in
a combo suddenly it does something
circle is a long-distance attack that
most enemies just block but occasionally
you can tag them with it and knock them
back when you're getting overwhelmed the
character movement is slow and stiff
which is only accented by a camera that
you can't control and you're always at
the mercy of when it decides to change
in the middle of combat none of the main
heroes feel unique in any way and all
play the same way there's no special
scenarios that can only be solved by one
character no gameplay mechanics built
around their special talents you can
play through the game with two
characters and it doesn't really make
any difference which ones you pick they
break up the gameplay every once in a
while with QuickTime event sequences and
these are entertaining if only for the
amount of ways you can choose to fail
them and watch the hero fall on his face
or splatter in a comical way the level
design really lacks any creativity or
imagination the missions are all very
short and small often with repeating
architecture or very bland scenery you
spend a lot of this game in cramped dark
hallways which is disappointing
considering how fun and colourful
everything looks at first glance it
often pushes you into doing very
repetitive tasks like fighting wave upon
wave of enemies until the game decides
you can progress protecting some random
soldiers who are doing menial tasks like
hacking a computer or you'll just end up
running through very samey stretches of
corridors trying to collect an item
that'll open to the door to a hallway
where you do the same thing over again
yeah it's like they use the same design
philosophy as destiny let's not also
forget moments where the progression
becomes very difficult because they
decide to be obtuse and pick some a
random object in the environment that
has to be destroyed in order to leave
the room which wouldn't be so bad if the
hit detection on some items wasn't so
broken I can absolutely see a younger
kid getting frustrated and bored with
this game very quickly and it's not
challenging because it requires a lot of
thought or skill but because the game is
constantly testing your patience before
you lose interest and turn it off all
right since you're determined to do it
anyway write your comments now because I
was so hard from the game a few dozen of
you do it every time there's anything I
can praise this game for it
they fixed Galactus his face from the
toy Jesus he looks like Thomas the Tank
Engine devourer of worlds but otherwise
the lazy game design non-committal style
and tone bland gameplay and ugly visuals
make this one of the lesser Marvel games
out there let's compare this to Lego
Marvel rather than an infinity sword
it's a silly but appropriate case of
cosmic Lego bricks getting spread
throughout various Marvel landmarks
there are more levels more cutscenes
more actual boss fights instead of just
pushing the bad guys out of bounds ten
times and more memorable Marvel
locations I immediately have to
appreciate how the game looks visually
everything is so bright and colorful for
the majority of the game but the
lighting and tone can change depending
on the mission they even did the dark
and stormy Prison Break at the raft
before spider-man got to it and this
little side mission with daredevil and
Elektra feels like an old Frank Miller
comic you may notice going back to this
one that a lot of looks characters and
locations feel very MCU inspired which
is not surprising at all anymore because
that's become the default for everything
comics are just advertisements for the
movies and shows now I miss the old days
when they were only advertisements for
toys at least the comics were dictating
how the figures looked and not the other
way around although we're also talking
about two games designed after toys this
is becoming the weird met a chicken and
egg thing and I'm confusing myself but
hey at least they gave special attention
to x-men and Fantastic Four and even a
little bit of Andrew Garfield Spidey
since this was before he got canned and
Marvel started cracking down and
removing those characters from
everything until they got the rides back
this is the second coolest boss fight
with The Sentinel
anyway we've all played Lego games at
one point or another because they keep
enveloping IPs and franchises we like
dating all the way back to the only way
to make the Star Wars prequels enjoyable
they're sort of like telltale games just
coming out constantly with the same
gameplay formula applied to a new brand
each time the difference being that
these games are successful and like more
than three of them are good I think if
there's anything that speaks to the
longevity of these games is that they're
just good games like they're fun and
well-designed usually the two-player
co-op feels useful and well implemented
because they actually give both
characters something
to do Ironman could solve puzzles Hulk
can't and vice versa Reed Richards can
use his powers to pull off crazy moves
that Captain America can't because he's
not a scary rubber stretchy man that's
secretly evil in every timeline what
this does is make the character feel
very useful and unique in some way
instead of a big nuisance
what Super Hero Squad didn't understand
is that a co-op partner that doesn't do
anything just feels useless when playing
the game solo you gotta have all these
same missions with only the one
character that appears in cutscenes and
it wouldn't affect a thing while as in
Lego Marvel you get to see every
character pull off something special
that only they can do which gives you a
better sense of identity for each one
sure characters fit in subcategories to
agree and a lot of them have the same
powers but they managed to do that in a
way that feels fitting so every
character isn't just a palette swap on
the model Black Bolt has the same energy
projection power as most characters but
it comes from his mouth and he has a
screaming sound effect and a unique
flying animation based on his costume
venom has all the same powers as
spider-man but they also give you the
option to choose between Topher Grace
virgin venom and Chad Tom Hardy venom
mid gameplay and to be fair a decent
amount of these characters power sets
really are just a reskin of some other
guy with one or two extra gimmicks don't
even get me started on how there's to
make damn flashes and Spider Men I think
something that makes the Lego games in
general feel so addictive is the amount
of unlockables and progression within
the game itself and how clearly and
easily it's laid out what you need to do
to get them all I see a character select
screen with God knows how many adorable
plastic angular landmine Schmucks in it
but it very quickly becomes apparent how
I get the ones I want most they're all
just listed on the map from the very
start
wanna play is obscure spider-man villain
that's always fleeing boss fights the
beetle well he's right over there just
do this quick minigame in your set let's
see how Super Hero Squad handles this
playthrough the level to get the
characters in the level all right that
works that's just like than the other
thing but what about all these other
guys just play the level two more times
yeah that's fun and again it doesn't
matter much anyway because half of them
you can't play with in the story mode
hell even spider-man who is
dead center of the boxart on the game
cover you have to unlock by finding all
these tokens in the story mode and you
can't use him in the story either I will
however give a point to this game over
Lego Marvel and that he's voiced by Josh
Keaton
while the Lego version is voiced by
johnny test a friend or foe Fame both
however are superior to another thing
that praised Lego Marvel 4 is the sheer
amount of characters they threw in
giving special attention to a lot of the
coolest ones like a side mission and
dialogue in the open world for Ghost
Rider or Punisher even Deadpool is here
and they really make you work for it to
unlock him wow this is the best Deadpool
related thing to happen in a video game
in 2013 we could be a team you can get
fame money
don't forget the [ __ ] there's not
gonna be Fame and there's not gonna be
[ __ ] okay I didn't ask for any of
this I just want to be like everybody
else this game is just so weirdly packed
with content between the fully
explorable open-world map and the great
replay value on various levels once you
go back with extra characters and powers
all these side objectives and unique
encounters all the time and care put
into it what separates these two most
for me is that this one doesn't feel
half-assed in any way whatsoever which
is surprising because these games sell
like hotcakes and you'd think they'd get
lazy every once in a while while making
them especially attached to such a
massive brand like Marvel which pretty
much guarantees it'll be a financial
success just because made for kids
doesn't mean it has to be mindless and
lazy even some of the games hundreds of
puzzles can stump an adult every once in
a while Lego Marvel has time and energy
put into it with an appreciation for
every character included the attention
to detail makes it feel like a really
genuine love letter to Marvel and even
if you're a bitter angsty adult with
bills to pay in a Twitter account full
of political screaming and all caps that
leave you feeling nothing but emptiness
you can still sit down and play this and
feel like a kid again well as this one
feels like a rushed haphazardly put
together mess that was just designed to
build hype for a cartoon rather than
stand on its own its lacks the same
heart god I sound like Scorsese but hey
maybe you liked it when you were 7 years
old so you're still going
right that comment about how it's
actually an underrated gem and I'm just
mean and you had to be there man it was
good for the time even though I played
it at the same age and didn't like it
then either that being said if we just
ignore the crap that resulted from it
I still love these charming little toys
and I'd collect them again in a
heartbeat if they came back in some form
no not those lame Imaginext style
knock-offs
I mean a proper return unique poses and
a billion costume variants and all I
only knew what Ironman 2020 was because
of this figure and they still need to
make one for sly
[Music]
[Music]